demain un enjeu qui va sûrement pesé sur
la campagne électorale celui de l'école
libre l'enseignement catholique dont le
comité national s'est réuni hier a
confirmé aujourd'hui son refus de
négocier l'avenir de l'enseignement
privé sur les bases proposées par le
ministre de l'éducation alain savary la
résolution du comité national exige des
garanties en préalable à toute
discussion
lawrence yun pour la carte scolaire
l'enseignement catholique refusent
l'affectation obligatoire des enfants à
une école en fonction de leur domicile
par contre il convient qu on peut
harmoniser l'implantation des écoles
privées avec celle des écoles publiques
pour la nature juridique des écoles
privées ils refusent leur transformation
en établissement d'intérêt public ou la
participation de l'état des
collectivités locales serait majoritaire
il est prêt en revanche à accepter un
cahier des charges à condition que
l'école garde un statut privé pour les
personnels l'enseignement catholique
refusent qu'ils deviennent des
fonctionnaires sont donc non négociable
la liberté de choix des familles
l'autonomie juridique la liberté de
fonctionnement des établissements
monsieur ministre savary a bâti lui-même
son projet nous avons en face essayer de
bâtir quelles étaient nos bases de
départ en notre base de départ essentiel
c'est le maintien d'établissement
d'initiatives privées associées au
service public d'éducation sommes prêts
à discuter avec le gouvernement pour
savoir dans quelles conditions
les collectivités locales pourraient à
la fois soutenir et je dirais presque
contrôler l'emploi des sommes et cela
pour nous le contrôle n'est pas un
problème et lille ensuite au point du
corps enseignant l'établissement d'un
statut propre de professeurs
d'enseignants contractuels
parce que l'afl la fonctionnarisation si
vous voulez obligé du corps enseignant
pose à beaucoup de nos enseignants et
j'irai même aux trois quarts de nos
enseignants beaucoup de problèmes
il faut maintenant attendre la réaction
d'alain savary à ses contre propositions
très éloignées et parfois à l'opposé du
projet ministériel